e
e e
but we have a slight unusual Arrangement
this morning because the chair and the
vice chair are both unavailable today
and thus as senior member which Falls to
me to uh chair the meeting um and I will
ask Michael to tell us who is sitting
and for whom among our
alternates Senator gray could sit in for
Senator Lang
uh representative grassy well I'm sorry
he's not here yet uh representative
fellows could sit in for representative
Maguire and Senator Whitley can sit in
for
herself I'm sure you're feel up to that
Senator so we have several postponements
could you please tell us which ones and
and we'll have a motion on
that um would you like to do the minutes
first sure um so do we have a motion on
the minutes move by by SEC by represent
Senator Ward second by Senator gray uh
are there any corrections emendations or
what have you see none all in favor say
I I opposed that's unanimous thank
you
that's now uh the consent agenda do we
have anything to be
removed not that I'm aware of okay let's
let's pause for a moment while sen while
representative grass takes a
seat are there any any it M to be
removed from the consent
calendar seeing none all in favor say I
I
opposed takes care of the consent
calendar
so chairman Deus you're going to stick
around for while right thank you
good so now let's let's get to the
postponements okay uh could you tell me
who the made the motion and second on
that um I believe I made the motion to
approve but I don't think anybody
seconded it okay you I didn't hear who
was who was the second okay
okay um also uh representative Grassi
has entered the meeting he could sit for
representative
Lon
okay very good so now we have several
items to be postponed would you
please on the regular agenda
um items B and C from the installation
Standards Board final proposal 2023
279 and 2023 302 can both be postponed
along with item D from the Department of
energy
20428 um
and item g e xrf
2024-the the first three items uh b c
and d will require a
waiver I just have a motion for that
could I could I ask a question please
could you please why are these being
postponed at the agency's request they
still want to do further work on the
rules okay thank you in some instances I
know they want to do a conditional
approval but they got our comments
fairly late and didn't have enough
time thank
you
second that was gray and Becky Whitley
senat gr say who made the motion tost to
wa so Senator gray did you have a
comment or you're just making the
motion thank
you okay further comments on the
postponements seeing none all in favor
say I I I that would include the waivers
in those instances where the waivers are
necessary okay so I think that leaves us
ready to start with uh item 202
2467 okay who has that that would be my
rule okay um so this is from the
Department of Business and economic
Affairs that's on the housing Champion
program the department did file an
amended conditional approval and the
only remaining comment is on page 35 of
the amended conditional approval after
the department Awards
a um Grant or a loan to a municipality
or a private developer and that award is
approved by the governor and the
executive Council the department will
then enter into an agreement with the
award e and there is um a
potential basis for objection that these
agreements were are rules because they
are going to be applied to people
outside of the agency and they may
impose requirements on these individuals
or these awardees that would apply to
other awardees um so under the
definition of a rule under 541
A14 uh it would technically be
considered a rule but the committee has
taken varied positions on this
interpretation um for example last year
when the department of administrative
Services brought their procurement rules
before the committee even though
multiple
uh agreements by the department of
administrative Services were the same uh
the committee did see that there were
some differences and therefore found
them more to be contracts as opposed to
rules uh so that is the only comment I
have on this rule
set would you like to tell us who you
are this morning and uh probably the
same person's regularly as well
uh so uh and then tell us what you think
about the contract rule aspect uh thank
you very much uh committee members my
name is Chase Hegman I'm the director of
economic development at Bea introduce
yourself Andrew my name is Andrew Dorset
I'm the Housing Finance director at Bea
for the invest New Hampshire
program and just to follow up on the um
attorney ricard's comments um the
purpose of this Clause is simply to
identify that Awards or agreements with
would be entered into with the with the
um uh recipients of funding that would
then go to governor and Council for
authorization uh the agreements
themselves would effectively be
contracts um uh subject to terms within
uh the state standard p37 or G1 plus uh
any terms relevant to their specific
application within the program so the
scope of the project um would be the
more customized terms within each
contract
okay well the the jel car has
approved similar things in the past on
the basis of being contracts uh but it's
our call again this time so do we want
to have a discussion of
that seeing that so we're okay with
viewing them the same way the agency
does do we have a
motion to approve Senator War motions to
approve and Senator Chanley seconds Is
there further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I opposed that's unanimous thank you
thank you very much thank
you okay so that's brings us to 202
2449 so uh 202 2449 is on school nurse
lure uh for the Board of Education and
the only issue is that the interm rules
expired June 12th 2024 and so jacom may
have questions about enforcement since
that
time hi I'm Susan Blake I'm an
administrator for the Bureau of
credentialing for the Department of
Education uh Julie Shay administrative
rules coordinator for Department of Ed
okay what's the what's your position and
what has been done if anything in the
period of
expiration um we have not processed any
school nurse applications or renewals
for incoming um school nurse
certifications so we're holding
okay further
comment do I hear a
motion move by Senator chandley seconded
by represent grassy I believe forther
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I opposed that's unanimous thank you
so much thank you you have your rules
okay so that brings us to the pharmacy
board who has that so that one also is
an expired Rule and um the summary of
comments actually states that the boards
had no disciplinary actions um during
the expiration but like as always it's
an expired rule so you may have
questions
good morning Shantel wheeler rules
administrator with
oplc okay
and and what what if anything has been
done During the period of expiration I
could confirmed with the uh board
administrator that nothing no action has
been taken for disciplinary purposes for
the these roles since the period of
expiration so do we have further
questions points of interest I will
entertain a
motion Senator Ward moves to approve
second by representative grassy Is there
further discussion see none all in favor
say I I opposed so that's unanimous as
well so is that
everything sorry for taking so long but
I'm new in this
job uh we have nothing under other
business uh if you wish you could vote
to uh cancel the continued meeting
moved by Senator graay second by
representative Grassley further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppose
Nay it's everyone thank you so we're
done for